well in your book you have a chapter
from scanning on amazon about reluctant
subjects
how do you bring them out of their shell
or maybe there's no way around it there
are a few ways to deal with a reluctant
subject and it it always revolves around
what it is they're so worried about
is there people who think that well you
know this show isn't going the way i
thought i thought this was going to be a
show about how amazing i am and how i'm
starting a business and how i have all
of these things going on for myself
people have an agenda when they come in
um
and if those people aren't getting their
needs met as far as meeting their agenda
they're gonna start clamming up and
wondering what it is you're trying to do
with them and they're gonna embarrass me
and they're to this is going to happen
you can't allow it to get to that point
and even if that means let's try and
figure out a story line that does what
it is you want
you want to show us that you're a good
mom you know what let's do something and
we'll do
a three beat story with you and your
kids going somewhere we'll figure out
some way to accommodate that if even if
it never makes it into the show
you know to do that in good faith and to
work with your cast and try to help them
feel comfortable we'll get them over the
reluctant the reluctancy to appear on
camera
they just everybody needs a little bit
of
a little bit of help and a little bit of
encouragement and and most of all
information through the process you
can't just starve them for information
what about though there if there needs
to be something that's something needs
to be addressed let's suppose they want
to see it one-dimensional where they're
just this great person or a star but
really there's a reality there where
there's some serious holes and things
right how do you deal with that the
conversation that i've had to have
a few times is
i talk a lot about that if you see in
the book i talk about self producers
which is an extension of the reluctant
subject
a person who is self-producing again has
that agenda that they want to show you
the one side and they don't think it's
coming across so they're going to shut
down
self-producers you need to let them know
that you are trying to hit broad story
with them like i need something that's
going to translate
to what's out there
and also if you start putting on
a phony persona
on the show
you can't maintain it
for months
you're going to crack at some point and
what's going to happen is you're going
to look really unauthentic
like if you have one character on your
show who just has to be seen as the
goody two shoes just has to like oh i
don't want people to know that i'm
nasty or mean or i'm going to get into
fights like any other normal human being
would
and all you ever do is cut to shots of
them going oh my
and if you never show the two hours of
them mixing it up and getting into the
argument and getting passionate about
something the audience knows when you're
holding material back from them
and those self-producers are are going
to do themselves in and look like
phonies and there's nothing that anybody
hates more in reality tv than someone
who's being inauthentic